so what we doing here then so again  today we've got some bangers it's gonna  be loud yes all right let's film it all  right let's see yeah yeah that was  bright yeah yeah so I was always forced  to eat melons as a kid I don't really  like them so I have a little bit of  revenge with a banger and that  oh cool huh I got hit in the thumb while  I was running  oh hello thanks for watching that video  I'm just quickly going to mention  another channel that I found this week  it's called smarter every day it's run  by an American guy called Destin who has  his own phantom and so if you like  slo-mo be sure to subscribe to him you  start some really cool stuff like firing  bullets to light matches and firing guns  underwater and shooting eyeballs and  stuff all in slo-mo a pretty cool stuff  you might seen some already but  ambitious check eyes channel here and be  sure to check back right here next week  for a special one-year anniversary  edition of the slammer guys